Hi,
hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Hi, hi.
Hello.
Unravel the mystery of the druids.
That's what I'm going to do.
I can't wait to know what secrets they hold.
It was a huge pain in the butt getting this game set up per usual.
My retro gaming era continues.
to be of difficulty but we are here actually wait let me double check wait okay okay it's my dpi is kind of messed up when so my mouse as you can see is a little slow but we we're here so it's fine
but somehow somehow oh i don't i don't want to get into it i'll get frustrated all over again but we're here yes um i don't know anything about this game mystery of the druids i know nothing so i'm excited to play it um for those curious i did get the gog version so we shouldn't have issues and yeah um I don't know what else to say oh I have to start like a new game because it immediately starts with a with like a cutscene and I was like well I want us to watch that I haven't tested the audio or or anything I haven't done anything we don't know who they are what they were doing but their Stonehenge was in danger of being trodden i saw that's in the opening i had to watch it to test it sorry so you're not going to get my first reaction with the opening cutscene but yeah there's a there's a there's several babies there's several babies actually right off the bat the box art has already sent me into the afterlife i wanted to i saw someone commenting about the thumbnail where it was like
the juxtaposition of the anime girl and then the scary man screaming was kind of something and I was like I did that on purpose at first I was like maybe I'll go with like a serious serious thumbnail picture but then I was like wait what if it's like so funny that it's this ugly old dude and and cute anime I was like I want really cute art that like doesn't fit the theme at all My favorite baby's the one on the lower right.
But you're going to give me a binky?
I'll shut up.
I won't speak the whole rest of the time.
Thank you for satisfying a 25-year-old mild curiosity.
I really, I know that there's like videos about this game.
I guess what do you call them?
The YouTube essays.
But I have never watched them.
going in completely blind for this game so no spoilers i suppose unless um unless i need help with like um well i could always look up a walkthrough maybe maybe i'll look up my own walkthrough i don't know oh boy oh boy indeed oh boy indeed red supray oh okay okay so i didn't know that they did it hmm but um one moment oh my gosh my computer my you guys don't even know what every wait a second this is correct right yeah yeah i think so my computer is so messed up right now you guys don't even understand i think it's correct i think that aspect ratio is okay i think so the mystery of the druids the druids druids am i saying it wrong i am the walkthrough i wrote a guide ever since i saw your schedule i've been recommending this game for but wait did you really matt okay matt you're gonna be our go-to guide but only if i need help i'll be like matt matt took off leave for october 1st second oh my gosh jimana thank you wait why did you take It didn't need to take off work.
Thank you, though.
Also, shut the hell up about the hashtag ad in the loading screen.
That shit's going to be up until literally October 1st, day of.
You can shut your mouths.
If you knew how much money I was spending on this, you would also shove it in your face.
So, shut up.
Shut up.
And I'm, in fact, because there are haters, I'm going to play it again.
I'm not.
I'm going to show it again.
Here we go.
The announcement.
This!
My 3D debut live is on my birthday.
So come watch it.
Come watch.
Come one.
Come all.
It's free to watch.
All you have to do is watch.
I love ads.
this game is such jank i'll i'll we've gone through jank before so you should keep it up till next year
right so um what was i gonna say i don't remember anyway it doesn't matter put the ad behind chat
yeah can you show it again sure of course Of course.
Like that.
October 1st, October 1st, October 1st, October 1st, October 1st, October 1st.
October 1st, I don't shill anything, so you know it's a big deal of me if I push it.
I don't push, I don't, I don't ever do anything.
Okay.
Let's start a new game...
New game!
More ads!
Oh my gosh, 51 cards!
Thank you so much for the...
Akka!
Thank you!
You should add the date and time to the thumbnail.
Nah, I think it'll ruin it.
It'll look ugly.
I decided how I wanted it to look, so that's how I chose it.
Okay, new game!
Oh, wait.
Wait.
I know what.
There we go.
Okay.
You'll be able to hear it now.
You should.
I don't hear sound.
Where's the sound?
Okay.
Can you hear it?
They say yes.
It's really quiet right now.
It's...
It's low?
Yeah, it's low in general.
Okay.
Cool!
Okay, as long as audio is working.
Thank you.
Mystery of the Druids.
Druidist mission.
This
is some spookies.
Perfect for the season.
Oh!
Wait, those are some giant people.
Wait, am I...
crazy?
Oh, are those shadows?
I can't tell actually.
I think... there are shadows?
I'm just small.
Wait, those are definitely shadows.
Oh.
Ruins.
I guess these are druids.
Are these our guys?
What's this party for?
I think this is a birthing party.
Okay.
Look at all these babies!
Two babies.
And...
Three babies!
Wait, I was so preferred to say two more babies.
Look at him go!
Yeah!
Woo!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Wait, I don't remember...
Okay, I definitely was not paying attention during this conference.
Just...
Ah, everybody's dead!
Oh, wait.
Oh, lucky, lucky three.
The three babies!
No way.
The three people and the three babies.
Unfiltered experience time, Ikuzo.
Wait, I turned on subtitles.
What do you think the press are going to say about it?
Oh, one second!
Now get out of here!
Get the hell out of my sight!
I just closed something for me.
Okay, we're fine.
I thought it closed the game.
If I have any more trouble with you, you'll be dishing out parking tickets before long.
That's a promise, Lowry!
Lowry!
Okay, I'll turn on subtitles right after this.
I don't want to accidentally skip the cutscene.
Oh, and here's my good friend Halligan.
Another one of the invaluable detectives of our glorious murder squad.
just stand there gaping come in yes I'm glad you could make it after all you're a busy man aren't you I'm so busy no smoking in here well there's so many guns on there I got used to being surrounded by a bunch of incompetent half-baked blockheads but your smart well-dressed colleague Lowry has just earned himself the golden badge of stupidity oh wait I thought Lowry was was good at his job the literal face bomb we've got a bit of a problem we've had an innocent man locked up in jail oh regrettably he was killed in prison oh before we could correct our mistake why didn't you just take him out now we got this lunatic killer running around all over London London we have to make sure that at least this oversight is put right he's staring directly at me your clear-up rate so far ought to be sufficient evidence just looking at the camera there's no point in asking you to clear up anything more than a common bicycle theft but this does happen to be the murder squad I am the chief of this
department all I have for choice is that blockhead Lowry oh that's me wow my okay chief what do you want me to do my lashes are yourself my gosh okay um let me uh game settings subtitles on okay there we go um let me know how the audio is it should be all good okay great great great so we have our we have a little menu down here can i click on anything jeffrey b miller let's talk to him
Where did Lowry go wrong?
Your dear colleague Lowry dealt with the skeleton murders last year.
Skeleton murders?
Lowry worked on the case for several months.
Wait, is he so quiet?
A butcher from South London.
A married man with kids.
Okay, I'll turn- I'll change that.
He was in jail till three weeks ago.
Okay.
Hold on one moment.
Wait, okay.
Game setting, let's do this.
Voice volume.
Ooh.
okay oh okay we'll do like this a little down okay let's try that let's try that I have something being made for you for your birthday really yeah um a butcher how fitting why did he do it a butcher how fitting and why did he do it You'll be surprised,
Hulligan.
He probably didn't do it at all.
Oh.
You didn't.
How could he be convicted then?
He didn't do it.
Detective Lowry imaginatively constructed an impressive chain of evidence.
And the court followed his arguments in detail.
The public wanted somebody to blame, and they found somebody.
That's life.
Minky British accent.
Okay.
The whole time I stream.
How do you know the man that the man Lowry arrested didn't commit the murders?
Then the case seems to be closed.
How do you know?
Well, all right, these things happen.
But how do you know that the man Lowry arrested didn't commit the murders?
Very simple.
Dead people don't go around committing more murders.
It's a copycat.
There's been another murder.
Exactly, Alegon.
A pile of bones has been found in Epping Forest.
Oh, supposedly a male corpse.
We don't know any more than that.
Can't have been Lowry's, man, eh?
Oh, Lowry, how could you drop the ball so bad?
I just managed to get that into Lowry's head as well.
You heard it?
Lowry's off the case.
Uh-oh.
Alligan, you drive out to Epping Forest and take a look at the evidence.
Of course, sir.
Yes, sir.
And Alligan, no sloppiness now.
I want results.
Sensible results.
The press has already been terrorizing me this morning.
The killer must be found.
Do I make myself...
Of course, chief.
Good.
This is the fire with all the necessary information.
and now you better get going quickly.
Yes, sir.
What else we got in here?
Can I talk to you?
What else can I...
No, I don't think we need to say anymore.
Um...
Wow.
The union jack.
Let's get out of here.
Oh!
What is this?
Oh, are these our suspects?
Because there's like 20 people up here.
There's so many guns.
Wait, I don't...
I have a sneaking suspicion that...
Okay, I can't do anything with these.
I have a sneaking suspicion this is not about the skeleton murders.
Because why would they need guns?
Anything else?
No, no map, okay.
Alright, let's head out.
Dev photos probably And I Okay Oh this actually pulls up my That's interesting Okay so we have This What is this?
Never mind Oh we got Oh Copy there
I don't know Rush or anything It sounds like people are dying But I can do it again
It's the wink.
Wow.
Oh.
Ooh, science.
I'm running to the science.
I'm running.
Oh.
Far too hot to touch.
Okay, turn it off.
If I pull that hose off, the whole of Scotland Yard will blow up.
Oh.
That's not a bad idea.
He's kind of unhinged.
It'll blow up.
Far too hot to touch.
Hello.
Hello, Chris.
Hi, Halligan.
Um, there's work for you.
Have you heard of the new skeleton murder?
Kind of.
Not only heard, I've already been out to where the body was found, together with the forensic squad.
And, what did you find out?
Not a lot.
The killer did a neat job.
No traces, no witnesses.
This madman doesn't seem to be so stupid at all.
Unlike Lowry.
That guy doesn't know shit.
Did you examine the other cases as well?
Did you examine the other cases as well, Chris?
Of course.
What do you think these people died of?
It was no natural death, if that's what you mean, Heligan.
Oh, just drive out there and have a look at it.
Just you do that, Brent.
There, that poster right here, this one, it looks so sexy, no?
Like, it looks like some...
looks like big booty cheeks.
Nah, it's good.
Okay, Chris, see ya.
Okay, Chris.
See you later on.
It's a little sus.
No, it's, yeah, it's just something sexy about it.
Science is sexy.
Anything else in here?
Oh, here.
Ooh.
Too dangerous to carry the bottle around with me.
I don't even know what kind of stuff that is.
We got ethanol, but we also got but-in-all.
Ethanol?
More like but-in-all.
Snakes?
Could be.
Too dangerous to carry the bottle around with me.
I don't even know what kind of stuff that is.
It doesn't even know what it is.
There's nothing I can do with this.
He's like, yeah, I want to carry it, but it's too dangerous.
Science.
I can't do anything with this.
I can't even pronounce the name on the label.
right.
Oh, I got a thing.
This, I, whatever that was, it looked suspicious.
I can't do anything.
I can't.
I just can't.
Bro doesn't know Earth and all.
Okay, we took whatever that was.
It looked kind of mysterious.
Okay, so this door can't go in here.
So we'll go this way.
I love the way he rides.
His face is so funny.
Wait, that's just Straight up Coca-Cola.
Thank you so much for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sorry if I missed some.
I love mint.
But no.
Propaninol.
Ethanol.
But no.
Hello, Janet.
Hello, Brent.
Uh-oh.
Have you heard?
The chief has handed Lowry's case over to me.
has handed Lowry's case over to me.
Oh, sounds exactly the same.
Yes, and there was no way that I could have missed the conversation between the Chief and Lowry.
Uh...
Please have the necessary information ready by 2 p.m.
Well, not bad, isn't it?
and arrange a press conference.
Are you mad?
Look, I'm not your secretary, detective.
Any information in this department is to be treated according to Regulation 12A23.
case file and that will have to suffice if you need more information then you will have to get a 234 2 with one copy I need to make an inquiry Janet damn bureaucracy I need to make an inquiry Janet right now if you start shouting at me I shall see the chief before you can count to three do you understand I don't even know how to count that eyes come back when you've got the necessary forms sheet and get it signed damn it Janet you think that was a reference I need a signature who wait I thought chief Miller had just recently abolished the security regulations tell me have you been to the hairdressers Janet looks really great wait I want I need a signature whose signature oh my god Brent don't pretend to be more stupid than you are DLC for Indiana Jones in the Great Circle I haven't thought about it yet Maybe.
So I won't get anywhere.
So I won't get anywhere without it, then.
Exactly, Brent.
Rules are rules.
Good.
See you later, then.
I'm going to ask her about her hair.
Hello, Janet.
Hello, Brent.
Your hair, your hair.
Oh, nice day today, isn't it?
Nice day today, isn't it?
Don't trouble yourself, Brent.
I will not go to the cinema with you.
Wait, there's history here.
got your green scarf.
Do you want it back?
How do you know I was going to ask that, Janet?
There's us green.
No, Janet.
That's not what's on my mind at the moment.
I've still got your green scarf.
You want it back?
Oh, that ugly thing that the department gave me as a present for my birthday.
Well, I was hoping you'd either forget it or throw it away.
Just keep it, please.
It's autumn.
You'll catch a cold.
Well, that's still better than making a fool of myself by wearing such a scarf.
And now I don't feel like talking to you anymore.
See you later.
Janet, please.
Give me one more chance.
Janet.
Good.
See you later, then.
Take your time, Brent.
Today, isn't it?
Hello, Janet.
Hello, Brent.
Janet's relationship to you.
Wait, have you got a minute?
Have you got a minute?
Not even a minute, Brent.
Do I look as though I...
I've got any time oh we're just harassing HR HR can't you stop your work for a moment it's important can't you stop working for a moment what do you need oh I need I want to make a couple of inquiries at your terminal I just want to make a couple of inquiries at your terminal sorry Brent but there's no way you're going to do that,
not without proper authorization.
I've heard the cinema is bad for a date.
You would agree or disagree.
Whoa, I think cinema is great for a date.
Wait, who would say that it's not good for a date?
I guess you don't get to really talk to the person, but it's dark and quiet, and you can share popcorn, and then what if you both reach for the popcorn at the same time, and then your hands touch, and you're like, oh, yeah.
Yeah, and then afterwards, you get...
get to you can and then afterwards you can discuss the movie even if it sucked you could be like man that movie sucked
okay good see you later then bye take your time Brent take your time she hates me she hates me this is like chief hates Lowry future Oh, I just spat all over the place.
Future plan for London North.
I'll take that with me.
Is that?
You never know.
I might need it.
Did I just take a piece of...
Is that a napkin?
It's always handy having one of these tucked away.
It is.
You ran out not so long ago, and there was a big commotion on this floor.
What is it?
I'm taking things.
I don't know what they...
At least that's one thing you can get hold of here without too much trouble.
They are needed for the forms.
Makes it easier for the chief to sign them.
Oh, like, this is a clipboard.
Okay.
No?
All right.
The way he like jogs is just too funny.
What's this?
Oh,
Vernon Doyle!
Hello, Mr. Doyle.
That is Sir Arthur Conan Doyle, the author of Sherlock Holmes.
Can I get a can I get a drink?
got no money for that dang you actually only use it in case of fire okay so there are things that I can click on kind of just for commentary okay good to know he broke we gotta oh we gotta solve the big case we gotta solve the mystery of the druids howl again I've got a new case for you someone's been stealing stationary what can i turn it on oh cute no he likes cars he's a car guy he looks really mad are you okay all right let's talk to him wait can i oh i could sit next to him maybe oh
your legs.
Hello, Lowry.
Lowry the goat.
Oh, no, not you, Halligan.
You're all I need at the moment.
Um, it's a nice suit you're wearing.
It's a nice suit you're wearing.
Don't humor me, Halligan.
You don't know a thing about suits.
A blind man would know from a hundred yards away that you bought your stuff at Woolworths.
What do you want?
Oh, I do look a little bit like Colombo.
Wait, yeah, wait, his ass is dying.
Wait, he has no chair.
why is he floating
Scott Cavs of steel he can just hold himself up oh my god he's a hero he's a superhero amazing core strength let me see my wallet just want to say I'm sorry to hear that things went so badly um I haven't seen my wallet just a quick question Larry he's or a farmer you've seen my wallet your wallet you've got a nerve I haven't really had a very pleasant day so far,
as you might have noticed.
I think everybody hates me, though.
Why would I worry about your bloody wallet?
Oh, they changed.
They censored it.
The subtitle said goddamn.
But he said bloody.
They censored the British slang.
Larry, could you just give me a sensible answer?
I'm looking for my wallet.
We're just harassing everybody.
I've got it.
Why don't you just go and clear up your oh so tidy office?
That's good localization.
Maybe you'll find some of those things you allegedly just wanted to borrow for a while.
Thank you for being so friendly, Lowry.
Enjoy your spare time.
Let's not argue, Lowry.
I need some information.
I need some information from you about the last investigations.
Yes.
You've got the file, Halligan.
I suppose you can read.
Actually, I don't know how to open it, actually.
I've read your file.
There's just nonsense.
Oh.
I've read your file.
There's just nonsense in it.
You know what I think, Halligan?
I think I don't need to tolerate a detective and a 20-pound suit walking past my door criticizing the quality of my work.
Well, you got fired.
If my suit was more expensive, would that make your file any better?
Very witty, detective.
Yes, really.
very witty tell me haven't you got anything better to do than crack jokes laurie's aggressively blonde it's his that's pumpkin thank you for being so friendly thank you for being so very friendly very friendly enjoy your spare time just clear off Halligan I'm surprised he didn't like punch me okay how How do I leave?
I turned your fan on so you can cool off, buddy.
Okay.
We can take the elevator.
We could take another.
Societal menace!
Did you change your name?
I recognize your profile.
Thank you so much for the vibe gifted!
Oh, okay, so this has...
Wait, I'm not done here yet.
Ah!
Oh, I'm running back to the Scotland yard.
Okay, here.
This is my office.
No, kidding.
Okay.
Wait, who's this?
The quaint.
The cleaner will empty the ashtray.
Oh my god, no, you should be...
I won't find anything I could make use of now in there.
You should be cleaning after yourself.
Unfortunately, there's no pizza in there anymore.
No pizza!
There's no pizza anymore.
Click on the queen.
Oh!
Is that our boss?
There's no pizza.
Oh, okay.
Even if I leave, it switches it back.
I won't find anything I could make use of now in there.
This is so fine.
I can find my way without a map.
I know my way around well enough.
Well, then take it down.
If you don't need it anymore, smarty pants.
Chief Inspector Miller will get this file early enough.
How do I read the file that we have been given?
Oh, maybe here.
Okay.
Of course.
It can't work like that.
Oh, just kidding.
No, better not.
This man lacks maid instincts and doesn't know how to say pizza.
I guess there's not really anything in here.
Then.
I thought that was a family photo.
I really didn't expect the queen.
Oh my gosh.
Let me try right clicking it.
It just like puts it back in my inventory.
Like that.
Okay, let's go to where the murders are in the forest.
Epping forest.
Stupid Epping forest.
And people say Disco Elysium is the ghost of detective games.
We have this masterpiece.
How do I click on it?
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Oh.
Whoa.
Hello, Soft.
good morning officer good morning detective I hope you've had a good breakfast the sight over there is not very appetizing when were the bones discovered oh well you know I've got used to it when were the bones discovered at 530 a.m.
by a jogger he phoned us a jogger has we been interviewed 530 a.m.
I mean that's early but like that's so normal for running too a jogger has he been interviewed well he's in hospital for the time being what happened you know oh we could hardly even take down his particulars why was that he well he had to throw up several times sir oh I understand wait hold on sorry I keep messing up my setup you guys hold on one moment I'm gonna turn the music down just a tad bit more
Just a little bit more...
Uh, game settings.
That should be good.
The piano is just so loud.
Okay.
Always happy to get your streaming, though.
Thank you, Neptune!
Welcome back.
I think you'd love the FMV point-and-click mystery game contradiction spot the liar.
That sounds fine.
Um, could he have left the bones here?
Could he have left the bones here?
It's not impossible, but I don't really believe it.
He's a tourist and only arrived in London last night.
Oh.
I suppose he came here by accident.
He's a tourist.
Since when do tourists jog at half-five in the morning?
Is he on a fitness trip?
Sir, he told us he was a decathlete.
It's his job.
Okay, officer, that was it.
Thank you.
Anytime, sir.
Okay, officer, that was it.
Thank you.
Can I talk to them?
No, I want to be in the TV.
Oh, I have to leave first.
Let me be interviewed, please.
I'm very important to this case.
I'm the head investigator, after all.
As of 20 minutes ago.
Whoa!
V-Toy!
Thank you so much for the gifton!
90s, campy horror, minto, kinko, kino.
I love it.
Oh, wow.
You think you could construct a human from this?
I could.
Wait.
What do you want me to do?
I should take the bone with me, but...
But what?
I don't know what parts go to what.
Take it.
I should take...
You don't transport a piece of evidence in your coat pocket.
That might falsify traces.
Oh, he's actually...
Okay, you're right.
You're right.
My bad.
Uh...
Get me out of here.
Get me...
There we go.
Well, that was fascinating.
I looked at it.
What do you want me to do now?
Is there anything else?
Officer?
What is it, sir?
I've got the impression I've lost my wallet somewhere here.
Why?
You just got here.
Why would you think you lost your wallet?
I've lost my wallet and I think it may be here somewhere.
Have you seen it?
Are we the killer?
No.
Could you help me look for it?
Sir, I have to guard the scene of the crime.
I'm under orders not to leave this place.
But all my money was in the wallet!
But all my money was in the wallet.
Can't you just help me look for it?
I'm sorry, sir, but I don't have your wallet.
And I must not leave this place.
Would you please appreciate that?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Okay, officer, that was it.
Thank you.
Anytime, sir.
We gotta go back to the office.
That's where our wallet is.
Maybe.
Hopefully.
All right, back to the Scotland Yard.
Running is so funny.
My cat is in here with me, by the way, so I might have to let her out soon.
Is it a crime to leave your bones in the park now?
Apparently.
Do I have to go get the signature or whatever?
How'd you guys know it was pause?
Wait, what's this?
Oh, yoink.
What was it?
Oh, you said she.
Wow.
Hello, chief.
May I just disturb you briefly?
You're a pain in the neck.
Are you planning to start doing things just like Lowry did?
I need a signature for database inquiry.
I've been to see Janet.
Have you seen...
Have these absurd measures been introduced because of me?
Chief, I've been to see Janet.
Among others, yes.
They were introduced for your benefit.
What did I do?
Are you still cross with me because of that business with the Royal Fair?
of that business with the royal family what did i do indeed yes indeed detective the press and the inspector have made my life hell for eight weeks you should be grateful that we somehow managed to keep things under control but those sort of jokes are a thing of the past you and laurie will have to ask for my signature before you take a single step even if you just want to go to the toilet what did we do i need information from the central database it's about the skeleton murders but janet says she needs a signed 223.
yeah i've posted her on twitter before You've got it with you.
How nice for you.
And do you know something, Heligan?
I will not sign it.
Why?
I say to that.
Why not, Chief?
You don't need the database.
You've got the file.
Make the most of it.
Uh...
How do you expect me to conduct everyone letting me use the database?
How do you expect me to conduct investigations if you won't allow me to use the database?
Chief.
You'll have to get out of your backside and do your own work, Halligan.
I feel much more comfortable knowing that you and Lowry can't get up to any more nonsense with the confidential data stored in our database.
Okay.
Of course, Chief.
Thanks a lot.
Don't get stroppy, Halligan.
What am I supposed...
I can't even read the file.
Wait, I don't know how to read it.
Hold on, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go take it back to our good pal here.
Hey, buddy.
Do you know how to read this?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I took matches.
That's what it is.
Do you know how to read this?
Wait.
That would be stupid.
Okay.
Bye, Lowry.
It's a PDF.
Wait, what?
Wait.
Like, actually the game manual?
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Outside of the game.
Wait, so the manual that I saw that was a PDF?
That I have to...
Okay, hold on.
Documents.
Manual.pdf.
Okay.
uh preface
game features wait
okay hold on we would hereby like to congratulate you on having purchased this adventure game which is just destined to provide you with weeks of excitement and entertainment intriguing events and mysterious locations are waiting for you to explore them no doubt you can hardly wait to place the CD in your CD-ROM drive and begin your journey.
But before you do, do so, take the time to read this document in order to ensure that you can enjoy the mystery of the Druids and the best possible quality.
This manual will help you to install the game and select the game control.
Okay.
Wrong.
Um.
Guys, we have 3D characters with up to 1,000 polygons.
More than 20 characters to talk to.
High resolution 2D, 3D graphics.
More than 370 interactive scenes.
Wow.
Surround sound.
1000.
Um, controlling the game, magnifying glass.
Uh.
Picker time.
Thank you.
Okay.
When you pick up an item in the game, it'll appear briefly in the top right hand corner of the screen.
Then it becomes part of the inventory.
All items you have picked up will always become available in the inventory bar to bring up the inventory simply lower the edge touch the lower edge of the game screen with the cursor scroll through the items move the mouse left or right you will see arrow how do I open the thing though
it does say save your game save your game it says okay save game oh
Uh...
Minto.
Wow.
Whoa!
This document was written in 2001 after all.
Jade, thank you so much for the vibe gift.
The image, right?
The image was so funny.
Okay.
Uh...
Resume game.
Um...
Okay, let me go.
go back to the manual real quick if you become stuck consider the current situation what are you trying to achieve uh it doesn't say in the manual you guys lied the manual does not say what the what the files are does not say
i don't know what's going on what are we trying to achieve but can i copy them no me no uh it took 1 000 polygons to construct one of two bees but just shut up okay baby let's look for my wallet yeah i think i think she might have my wallet or let's check my desk oh oh what's this a pencil no no no no no play
I'd better leave that here.
Okay.
Well, who can I call?
It doesn't work like that.
You don't... It doesn't work like that.
You don't hear anything, and nothing happens either.
I never use the receiver.
That thing is just too heavy.
Using the loudspeaker is much more comfortable.
Okay.
They're too busy!
Wait, what is it in London?
Instead of 9-1-1.
Make sure that you make regular saves.
This game has around three hard soft locks.
I'm doing things slightly out of order.
Oh, thank you, Nine Ball.
Thank you.
9-9-9.
Oh.
Okay.
Um.
Is it Tay time?
Let's see, anything else?
Chief Inspector Miller will get this file early enough.
The cleaner will empty the ashtray.
Oh my god!
Can we sit and like ponder and read?
I won't find anything I could make use of now in there.
I don't know.
I'm already lost, I'm already stuck.
I won't find anything I could make use of now in there.
Walk through friend!
Solve these skeleton murders, Minto.
I'm too afraid to walk outside my cemetery.
Uh...
Drawers.
Ask Boss for a signature.
We already tried that.
This.
There's only superfluous stuff in there.
I didn't see this.
Ah!
I'll take it with me.
Maybe I'll give it back to Miss Browning today.
Yes, we will.
But is this dying to quit?
I'm determined to give up smoking.
Leave those alone.
Okay.
We're dying to quit.
what we are i'm determined to give up smoking leave those alone okay um i don't think those ones open so let's go back and give her the scarf it's she said it was so ugly it's like the most normal looking scarf i've ever seen was it this room or the other one okay good
you've done it now arii hello janet it's me again it's me again i can see that what is it have you've forgotten something again um what about my yeah what about my database inquiry now i don't like to repeat myself brent have you not been listening yes of course i have well then you know it all don't you sure in that case see you later brent wait good see you later then take your time brent hello janet janet it's me it's me again i can see that what is is it?
Have you forgotten something again?
Yeah, I think she's into me.
She's playing hard to get.
Um, thought I'd drop in.
Or wait, nice day.
Nice day today, isn't it?
Don't trouble yourself, Brent.
He puts his arms behind his face.
I will not go to the cinema with you.
I have your green scarf.
Wait, do you think going to the cinema with me is that bad?
Do you think going to the cinema with me is that bad?
Okay, then.
No cinema.
Why don't we just go down to the king's pub, have a pint, and Talk for a bit.
Listen, Brent, I don't feel like going to a stinky, cheap pub, drinking watery beer and talking about darts, pizzas, and aliens.
Oh, she can say pizza, so it's not just a British thing.
Janet, what's up?
Has Lowry been talking nonsense about me again?
Don't worry about that.
No, Halligan, and he doesn't need to either.
You talk enough of it yourself.
And now, please be good enough to let me carry on with my job, okay?
Lowry has been talking about me!
talking about me, and you believe every word he said.
I believe only what I see, Detective Halligan.
And right now, I can see a man right in front of my desk who is wasting my time.
Then Larry tell you that he's been fired off the case?
Good.
See you later, then.
Take your time, Brent.
Okay.
Anything here that I've missed?
What's this?
What about these?
No.
Trash can?
What's this?
No.
Ladies' coats don't suit me.
I love how nice and friendly all the characters are in this game.
It's the air, you know.
British air.
What about in here?
We only talked to this guy once.
She was about to say yes.
Just ask her one more time.
Hi, Halligan.
I've just come back from the place where they found the bones in Epping Forest.
Mm-hmm.
Why are you telling me?
Have there been any decisive discoveries in that case?
The writer is German.
Halligan says pizza.
Oh.
There was just a pile of bones.
There was a pile of bones.
Nothing else.
Yes, I had that impression as well when I was out there with the forensic squad.
Everything is quite clean.
You didn't find anything either.
No, nothing.
I would actually have been surprised if you had.
And why did you come here then, if I may ask?
Oh, I thought you might be interested in this.
Sure, Halligan.
Thank you.
Anything else?
No, that was it.
Well, then, see you later.
Well...
Okay, Chris.
See you later on.
What did I...
Hello, Chris.
Hi, Halligan.
I've just come back from the place where they found the bones in Apping Forest.
Why are you telling me?
Have there been any decisive discoveries in that case?
Sorry, I didn't realize it was the same thing.
thing we'll just click out of it okay um great so he doesn't care where's the druids at was there anything else at the forest or maybe alan anything in here that i missed
now that i know we can click on this or i tried before actually now i think about it nothing worked every time I clicked nothing nothing is nothing is getting said what about these no no no just running around this guy's office I'll take me a cup of water I'm not thirsty just kidding I'm not thirsty okay I don't need a map I know my way around London anyway it belongs to the chief right additional drawers in my office wait I thought I got all of them were there
more I'm surprised I have an office but this one it won't let me I won't find anything I could make use of now in there hmm I know the running animation is so funny was it this
I can't do anything with them the other ones oh oh check my coat oh yeah let's try that one is wet anyway I'm already wearing a coat where did I go oh
that one is wet anyway I'm already wearing a coat do I have to like open each individual one with the oh i see oh sock what is there anything worse than thirst i'll take it with me what is this what is this why is it in our drawer okay now i thought oh okay okay okay so i have to open each individual drawer with the magnifying glass wow okay what are these no no darts now maybe i'll play later against my favorite opponent in spectra Miller.
Oh, I grabbed something.
What are these?
Leave them.
I don't need those anymore.
What is that?
Oh, wait.
Are those all cigarettes?
Oh, my God.
Coat uses black hole technology.
All right.
We got something.
I don't know what that was.
I've already taken one this morning.
Okay.
What?
There's the other sock!
Ah!
We got gloves.
Okay, now we can go grab the bow.
Okay.
It's boning time!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Why do we have both socks and two different...
Okay.
In two different drawers.
All right.
Hello.
Let me use my hands.
That won't feel different with gloves either.
No?
That would be stupid.
That won't feel different with gloves either.
Just kidding.
What is this?
That is no important evidence, I'm sure, about that.
There's no point in that.
Oh.
The scarf.
Hmm.
That would be stupid.
Okay.
You're right.
I just thought it might work.
You have to select the big one.
I did!
This one?
I should take the bone with me, but...
I did select the big one.
Unless...
that won't feel different with gloves either it's a mystery maybe what's this do ah I grabbed it I grabbed oh okay so it's an evidence bag ah okay we got the bone oh wow that's a big old impression there I'm gonna take this bone hello officer any news no sir I just want to ask you something else yes sir
You said you know the other cases?
You just said you know the other cases.
That's right, sir.
Well, I read about them in the newspaper.
Um, what do you think the murderer does with the flesh?
What do you think the murderer does with the flesh of his victims?
That's too hard to answer, sir.
I haven't got a clue what goes on in lunatics' heads when they do things like that.
Maybe he freezes them.
Oh.
That's happened before.
That's such an interesting answer.
answer.
Something that a murderer would come up with.
He was murdered in prison.
Apparently the man sold the flesh of his victims to the butcher shop.
Apparently the man sold the flesh of his victims in his butcher's shop.
Can you believe that?
Wait, that was the wrong guy.
That's what they wrote in the Sun, but I'd rather not believe it.
We know that's the wrong guy.
If that was true, they have all become cannibals.
Okay.
Okay, officer, that was it.
Thank you.
Anytime, sir.
Yep.
See ya.
All right, let's go get this maybe, I guess, to the scientist man.
Yeah, yeah, run, run.
Is this what the Scotland Yard actually looks like?
Nice conversation.
It was full of lies.
Literally, Lowry was fired because it wasn't the butcher.
And then he's just like, yeah.
murdered.
It was the guy who killed him.
I've just come back from the place where they found the bones in that forest.
And?
Trail-blazing new findings?
I've got something here I'd like you to have a look at.
Yes.
Tell me.
Yes, I have...
this.
Here you go, Chris.
Have a look at this.
A bone.
Very likely the right thigh bone.
Ooh.
Why are you bringing it here?
I had a look at the bones with the forensic squad this morning.
I know, but I've still got a couple of questions about them.
Well, go ahead, then.
Okay.
Um, uh, uh, uh, uh, abnormalities.
Can you see any abnormalities?
I would have noticed them, Halligan.
No fractures, no bruises.
Everything quite normal.
Okay.
Uh, scorch the...
Did somebody maybe scorch the flesh off the bone?
No, definitely not.
That would look different.
I suspect that it was rather cut off, or maybe taken off with acid.
What sex was the victim?
him.
Judging by the structure of the bones, I think it was Mio.
I'll write that down in my reports as well, but I'll tell you right now that you won't get it before the end of the week, Halligan.
Come on, come on, Chris.
Come on, you could be faster than that.
You can't tell me more than that about the bones.
Chris, that doesn't help me.
There's really no more to say about the bones, Halligan.
Just wait for my report.
You'll have it all nicely written down then.
Or, hang on a moment.
If you're really interested, go and see Professor Turner.
He was supervisor of a friend's PhD thesis.
Oh.
That's how I met him.
He works in the Anthropology Museum.
Why is everyone an asshole at Epstein?
I don't know.
If anybody can say anything about the bones, he can.
Okay.
Thanks for the advice.
Don't mention it, Brent.
Yahoo!
All right.
We got a new lead.
We're going to go talk to a professor.
All right.
Halligan, I need you to run.
I don't need you to look cool and walk in slow motion.
He's not an idiot.
He's just a guy.
Museum of Oxford.
Whoa.
Go to those birds.
What's this right here?
I'd like to sit on this bench here all day.
But I don't have the time.
Lazy.
All right.
Inside.
Oh, closer.
Oh.
Surely they'll let us in.
closed due to renovation works great and now knock or knock try yeah break and enter locked are you one vibes maybe we can talk to this guy hello please why are you there we go um we could go this way music is so strong range locked locked oh yeah
are you crazy that's mine hands off okay oh we were just gonna take it hello my friend huh my friend oh maybe we can give him the scarf can i help you somehow help help nobody can help me hey don't despair everybody has a hard time now and then maybe i can do you oh just leave it i've lost everything i've got to give him the scarf no money no out flat no future i'm finished simply finished no have you tried working
have you tried working have you tried working listen mate do you want trouble are you from the benefit office or something like that bugger off you oh I didn't want to be impolite.
I'm just interested.
Bagger off, pal.
You think I'm on holiday here, right?
No, no, of course not.
I just meant...
Go on, save your breath.
Bagger off.
It's telling you to go.
I need to go.
Okay, I must be off now.
Well then, okay.
Okay, wait, hold on, I'm gonna give him this clear.
I should think about it again.
Just kidding, he doesn't want it.
Hello, my friend.
We're just, we're so friendly to everybody and everybody else hates us.
Um, how are you doing?
How are you doing?
What?
What do you want?
Um...
Oh, isn't it cold for you on the ground?
Isn't it too cold for you on the ground?
Ah, so what?
This stuff here.
It warms you up better than any heating.
What is it, if I may ask?
Cider, pal.
Really cheap.
And it's nice.
It goes down well.
It's the apple cider.
Can I have a drop?
Get your own bottle, mate.
Get me one as well.
my bottle's empty dang try this new neat thing called working um a bottle of gut right I have no actually I lost my wallet sorry I've got no money on me hmm no money aye we'll bag her off then I'll moiser wait I was trying to get back to the prompt about asking him okay I must be off now well then okay about the museum the beggar can make better use of them the beggar can make better use of them is there anything a trash okay hello my friend hello my friend we'll just go can i help you can i help you somehow help help steal it nobody can help me i tried hey don't despair everybody has a hard time now and then maybe i can do something for you uh just leave it i've lost everything everything this is so sad are you okay no future i'm finished anyway about the museum um have you seen anyone going into you've seen anybody going in the museum yeah just this morning okay a woman a young pretty one a woman you haven't seen a man nah only a woman she comes here every day oh now and again she
gives me a few pennies I think she works in the museum a pretty lady what's special about that ah there are millions of women running about in this world why is the museum why is the museum being closed well it's been refurbished moment.
My business is running really badly.
How much did you make today?
Well, just epoxy 60 pence.
What does that mean?
Tell me in freedom words.
Okay, bye.
Okay, I must be off now.
We're gonna go meet a female!
Lucky day, lucky day!
What's over here?
A young pretty woman?
Could it be mean, though?
You think I'm young?
What's over this side?
Wait, maybe this is her car.
Maybe if we break into it.
Oh, just kidding.
Phone a friend.
Aren't you 19, yeah, but...
How long have you been 19?
A while.
Twilight.
What is this?
Oreg army killer?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Hello?
Why is it so slow?
I can't hear any dialing tone.
Oh, because we have no money.
We can't use it.
Okay.
So that's a...
My grandfather once told me that no woman is ever older than 29.
Your grandpa is a smart, smart man.
Um, huh, maybe we try again.
Wait, maybe we can take his...
You think we have to, like, make it so that he goes to sleep?
I don't know what to put in there.
And then we take his money?
Close due to renovation works.
Great, and now?
Or...
Because I probably feel like we have to call somebody.
Now you're thinking like Hal again.
Let's try again.
Let's try and steal his cash.
What's he going to do, run after us?
Here.
Are you crazy?
That's mine.
Hands off, okay?
I need to make a very important phone call.
Okay, if I were...
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I have a bottle of something.
This.
There you go, buddy.
I got you something.
Here you are.
What's that, pal?
Apple juice.
Naturally cloudy.
Lots of vitamin C.
juice are you pulling my leg didn't you say you were thirsty are you dense mister I want a bottle of cider apple juice is all right in a nursery but I'm not into that why don't you try get lost leave me alone you can drink your apple juice yourself why is it can you explain what a payphone is and how it works for the young people in the audience I thought this was maybe alcoholic I don't want that okay i'm gonna set him on fire think first brent okay just kidding let me show him the bone i don't want that okay um you sure you don't want that would be stupid okay uh oh wait can i take that the beggar's flask absolutely empty can i combine things right in front of his face now the flask is half full of apple juice I got you something here you are what's that pal apple juice no naturally cloudy lots of vitamin C apple juice don't be honest didn't you say you were thirsty are you dense mr.
I want a bottle of cider apple juice is all right in the nursery but I'm not into that why don't you try get lost leave me alone you can drink your apple juice yourself I have to ferment it how do you ferment something if I if I it up does that ferment it if i take it to okay halogen does not look both ways don't be like halogen if i take it to the science lab and put it on the fire the ethanol i don't know how alcohol works think like a psychopath he wants alcohol scarlet yard has medical ethanol yeah yeah yeah
take it with me okay here we go all right too dangerous to carry the bottle around with me I don't even know what kind of stuff that is propane no why won't it work maybe take it with me Chris there's nothing I can there's nothing I can do with this 90% a lot would he get white girl wasted
I can't see any connection there I can okay this is actually what I was trying to click on you would get a little more than wasted I can't do anything with this I can't even pronounce the name on the label right I don't think it's any of these since we can't zoom in on it I can't do anything
uh do we need like a little tube or something wait maybe we can can I borrow some ethanol please well halogen how'd you get on at the museum what did professor Turner say could he help you the museum is closed it's being refurbished oh well that's bad luck why don't you phone him my wallet has disappeared have you seen it your wallet no no it isn't here was there much money in it of 22 pound note a 20 pound note and some change i think that's a lot well it isn't here anyway okay chris thanks okay chris that's it for the moment ever clear is 95 percent see you then don't feel lightly okay so now maybe maybe we use maybe we instead of the flask we use the bottle this i saw someone suggest that let's try it oops goop goop goop goop goop
use the scarf of course it can't work like that use the scarf on what why is huh what
just happened
wait what it took 20 it's borderline esoteric but use the scarf on the bottles and talk to hecker who's hecker
Huh?
Am I drunk?
Am I...
Well, Halligan, how'd you get on at the museum?
What did Professor Turner say?
Could he help you?
Oh, yeah, what are those flasks contained?
Something I wanted to ask you, Chris.
What do those flasks contain?
Oh, you mean those on the shelves?
Yeah.
They contain all sorts of different chemicals I need for my work.
I see.
Indicator solutions.
Alcohol.
like that did you just say alcohol why do you need alcohol for your work why do you need alcohol for your work certainly not in order to drink it halogen we use alcohols as solvents most types are poisonous anyway oh oops sorry i was messing with my keyboard um you bottle some of the drinkable alcohol oh wait they're uh uh they're uh yeah he probably will say no right would you bottle some of the drinkable alcohol for me no way halogen do you think we supply the whole department with alcohol that'll be the day okay okay chris see you later on bye bye
oh wait uh what did the scarf do i i'm still i'm not sure I'm still not sure.
Let's see.
Try again.
Okay, run here.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Okay, and I'll talk.
Well, Halligan, how'd you get on at the museum?
What did Professor Turner say?
We need to get him to actually say like we're okay to...
Okay.
Yes.
Something I wanted to ask you, Chris.
What do those flasks contain?
Third choice?
Oh, you mean those on the shelves?
Okay, thank you.
I contain all sorts of different chemicals I need for my work.
Clean the dust.
Indicator solutions, alcohol, things like that.
Oh, okay.
This one.
Why do you need alcohol?
Why do you need alcohol for your work?
Certainly not in order to drink it, Halligan.
We use alcohols as solvents.
Most types are poisonous anyway.
And then you've got a great job, Chris.
You've got a great job, Chris.
Masses of alcohol and everything legal.
Nonsense, Halligan.
Do you think we spend all day getting drunk with medical alcohol?
Why don't you just try this stuff?
Oh, what will happen to me?
What will happen to me then?
You'll see.
Well, how about it?
Are you scared?
I think he wants me.
Sure, no problem.
Oh, he's gonna give it to me!
I think he wants to get me drunk.
Okay, Chris.
Oh!
We're in no... These are some shiny forms.
Here, Brent, to your health!
To my health!
What's up?
Go ahead, try it!
You won't go one of these so often.
All right, here we go.
Bottoms up!
Cheers!
Oh.
To your health, Brent.
An interesting aroma, isn't it?
Brent, aren't you feeling very well?
Brent, are you sure you're okay?
Oh, God!
he's laughing I'm dying he's laughing oh my god I have my head became deformed what happened to me oh it's my hair I'm awake somehow oh gosh god damn it you could knock someone out cold with this kind of stuff Chris Chris he's gone awesome her are insane my goodness all right now you could knock someone out cold wink wink wink wink
not this one maybe the bottle or maybe I just too dangerous to carry the bottle around with me I don't even know what kind of stuff that is we do know we drag it
Do I need to No
Propanol You're up soon I'm dying He's laughing Just like every good impromptu party Is it the but and all What
Huh Tuss the bottle for fingerprint think we're okay it does for fingerprints i don't even think there's a way for me to do that the small bottle too dangerous to carry the bottle around with me i don't even know what kind of too dangerous to carry too dangerous too dangerous to carry the bottle around with me i don't even know what kind of stuff that is none of these ones work i didn't think they would
Is it...
It's not...
There's nothing I can do with this.
I can't mix...
Take it with me?
Chris surely wouldn't like that.
Chris isn't here.
Who knows what's in it?
Chris isn't here!
Oh, Halligan needs to know which one the professor used.
What?
Wait, one second.
I'm also going to save the game.
Minto.
Save.
Yes.
Okay, resume.
All right, let's see.
Look for powder.
Like on another shelf?
I can't do anything with this.
I can't even pronounce the name on the label right.
I can't do anything.
I have the powder already.
Wait, oh my gosh.
It's so hard to tell what the stuff is in my inventory I don't think I have any powder do I oh this no not a chance just kidding no not a chance just kidding a matchbox still half full wait okay oh if I right-click it will it tell me what what is it fingerprint powder ah I see oh so if I right-click it it tells me what the thing is.
Otherwise, I have no idea what I'm picking up.
Okay, okay, okay.
Awesome.
Alright, then.
Which is it?
Whoa.
Look what we've got here.
This is the bottle Crystal.
Okay.
Perfect.
Awesome.
Or we can take it too.
Aha!
Okay.
Then I combine.
Aha!
Yes!
Alright, now let's go back to that guy.
How you doing, Pies?
Are you okay?
Stop.
I don't think it's a good idea to take the bottle out of the lab.
Chris will be back quite soon.
Okay, okay, okay.
He'll also notice all the powder that's like on the shelf.
You don't want to clean that up?
No?
Okay.
Why is 90% of the department's budget spent on supertests to a big phantom?
Don't play- Right!
Let's go knock a guy out!
Turn a homeless person?
He won't die.
He won't.
Run.
There we go.
Sometimes the way he walks in slow motion is so funny.
Hi, mister.
Hello, old friend.
Okay, I did just a tiny bit.
This guy is probably not a lightweight.
he'll be fine I've got something for you Apple snaps from detective Halligan's home distillery my own brand would you like to have a taste you serious all right pal I'm as dry as the bottom of a parrot's cage why don't you drink it all I don't mind and it's a cracker I can tell you cheers mr.
cheers oh
he's snoring you guys he's snoring I could hear him So we could steal $0.60 from a...
We need to make a phone call.
It's very important.
I wish I had a snack for this game.
I kind of want some cheeses.
I have some.
I just have to go get them.
Okay.
What shall I pay for?
The phone call?
You can't get through like that.
What are you talking about?
There we go.
This game is so obtuse.
I can't hear any dialing tone.
Yes, now I pay.
Now I...
What shall I pay for?
Oh, here we, in here.
Right here.
There we go.
Which number am I supposed to dial?
Uh...
Now he's dead.
No, he's not!
Wait.
I can't- it won't let me read this.
For some reason.
It won't work without money.
Um...
Wait, no, no, no, no!
I tried to click the books!
No, no, go back in, go back in.
It still is working, right?
I didn't like soft- okay, we have the money back.
Okay.
Ah, here we go, here we go, here we go.
Hmm.
Let's see if the phone number of the museum is listed in here.
Yes, yes.
Muse, Muse, Muse, Museum, Museum, Museum.
Museum of African Studies, Museum of Ancient History.
Here, Anthropological Museum.
Okay.
And the extension of Professor Turner?
It's here.
I've got it.
Aha!
Oh my gosh, easy peasy.
I would hate to, you know, hate if someone's if I don't want someone to bother hello who's that who am I speaking to this is detective Halligan from Scotland yard this is detective Halligan from Scotland yard Scotland yard what can I do for you I need to speak to professor Turner doesn't he work at the museum yes but he's away on business miss what was your name look miss what was your name goodbye mr.
Halligan wait she's hung up
Did I mess up?
I just wanted your name.
You can't get through like that.
Maybe if I go back urgently, Halligan.
Run, run!
What was her name?
Brizzless?
I've tried.
I have...
Oh, I do have money still, so I could try again.
Ma'am!
Okay, let's try again.
Locked.
Okay, I didn't realize.
I thought it took the money.
We're running, running, running.
Oh, so we could talk to a lady.
We killed a guy.
I think that's the bro code, no?
Like, I die for you to talk to a lady, right?
I don't know the bro code.
It is?
Okay, good.
Hello, it's me again, Detective Halligan.
Professor Turner isn't here.
Yes, but...
Detective, I'm very busy.
Please call again in eight weeks.
Are you pregnant?
Oh, wait, that's eight months.
Oh, gosh.
Imagine playing this game without chat to help you.
I'm getting soft logs without warning.
Weeks of fun, they weren't alike.
Right?
My goodness.
Wait, please.
I'm a desperate man.
You aren't drunk enough for this game.
okay one more time hello hello it's me again detective Halligan I told you professor Turner isn't here yes yes I'm very busy please call again in eight weeks but I she's hung up again oh okay I'll try one more time what is this thing anyway one more time one more time I have enough money hello hello it's me again detective haligan i told you professor turner isn't here yes but detective i'm very busy please call again in eight weeks but i she's hung up again oh okay all right have we considered the skeleton murders may might not be murders but in fact self-inflicted that is a possibility anything could be a pot they say sometimes truth is stranger than fiction.
They do say that.
Okay, I saw someone say go back to the Scotland Yard.
So that's where we're at, baby.
And we're going to get ourselves a drink.
I've got no money for that.
Um, excuse me.
What shall I pay for?
Oh, come on.
I think...
Because maybe he knows her too.
Hello.
Well, Brent, still got a headache.
Don't ask, Chris.
Have you managed to contact Professor Turner?
Yeah, I phoned him, but he wasn't in.
Not in?
He's on an expedition.
I just talked to some woman who works there.
With his extension number.
Yeah, exactly.
Well, Halligan, that was probably his daughter, Melanie.
She works in the museum as well.
My friend told me a lot about her.
He used to be really keen on her.
So, Professor Turner has a daughter.
Thanks, Chris.
I think that'll help.
All right, all the way back, baby.
Let's go.
Is this the true work of a detective just running back and forth, like actually running?
Just running and running?
Cute name, Melanie.
Is she single?
I think we're gonna romance her.
I just ran into the car.
Okay.
All right.
Fifth time's the charm.
Melanie.
Hello?
Hello, this is Halligan again.
Please don't hang up, Miss Turner.
How do you know my name, Mr. Halligan?
Chris Hecker told me that Professor Turner's your father.
Yes, that's true.
What do you do at the museum?
I'm an anthropologist.
The same as your father.
Yes?
Miss Turner, do you think you could help me?
That depends.
Why would she hang up on the Scotland Yard anyway?
I found a bone that I've had examined at the lab.
A bone?
A human bone?
Human bones.
Belong to a murder victim.
Murder?
How awful.
The bone is from the body of one of the victims of the skeleton murders.
I take it you've read about them.
Oh, good heavens, yes.
What can I do for you?
Couldn't we discuss that inside?
Certainly.
Come on over.
I'll let you in.
Yes, yes.
I want this thing, whatever it is.
All right, run, Halligan.
Oh, oh, she's waiting for me.
I mustn't keep a lady waiting.
successful yes mr.
Halligan yes that's right hello miss Turner she got that Laura Cropfield no problem we're closed anyway the museum is being refurbished it's not easy to get in touch with you I was close to giving up oh I mean because of the phone call I'm really sorry I do sometimes tend to be rather short on the phone no I get unpleasant calls sometimes and that's why I'm a bit suspicious I see well I finally got in touch with you would you like to come in would you like a cup of coffee or anything else no thanks mr.
Halligan how may I help you as I said I'm working on the skeleton murders we found another victim in Epping Forest all the evidence points to the same culprit as in the other cases the corpse was completely skeletonized professional that's horrible but how can I help you my colleague Chris Hecker of the forensic lab has already had a look at the bones he thought that your father could perhaps carry out some additional tests he is a renowned expert after all yes he could do that but as I said my father isn't here I know but it is very urgent perhaps you could have a look hmm you say you've got some of the bones with you yes just one just like my ears this is a femur yes that's what Chris Hecker said maybe we keep it in the bag.
It would take some time, Mr. Halligan.
Could you wait a moment?
What is this lo-fi version of the song?
Um, I would like to ask some questions about your work.
I would like to ask you some questions about your work.
Just out of interest.
Oh, well, uh, what's your research field?
What's your research field?
I specialize in sacrificial rights.
Sacrificial rights?
That's an unusual research field for a young woman.
Do you think so?
Such is like a sacrifice.
I don't think you should divide preferred science fields for men or women, Mr. Halligan.
No, I didn't mean it like that.
Participated?
I just think that you must have to do with death all the time if you research sacrifices.
Death is part of our existence, Mr. Halligan.
In all cultures, all around the world.
You're telling me.
Thank you so much for the fine good then.
If you take it like that, we are almost like colleagues.
Maybe.
But it's not my job to put people in jail.
I document the sacrificial rights of different cultures in order to help create a better mutual understanding.
is there to be understood about murder i'm not saying that i approve of everything i research mr haligan but in foreign cultures not all sacrificial rights are regarded as murder most cultures sacrifice animals or plants and they do so for religious reasons human sacrifices don't exist anywhere in the world at present they're a thing of the past bone sure it's a femur since it's a minstream i assumed it was a humorous that was very interesting i didn't listen i didn't pay attention i was i wouldn't pay attention to her at all that was very interesting thank you mr turner not at all i like talking about it i'm often alone here with my work it feels good to be able to chat but now i'll have a look at that bone you brought good okay good good good oh i'll just take a little why i'm her now oh my gosh How exciting!
She runs like Yuna, Final Fantasy 10-2.
Okay.
I want to go get cheeses.
Do you guys mind?
I'm just gonna get some cheeses.
Actually, I need some more water anyway, so...
I will be...
One moment.
And also, I'm gonna let my cat out.
You've been so patient, little girl.
You're so sweet.
Yeah, you've been so patient, wanting...
Yeah, you've just been laying on the ground.
Look at your clothes in your eyes.
You're so sweet.
You're the sweetest girl ever, ever, ever.
I love you.
No, yeah, you have RBF, but that's why you're so cute.
Okay, there we go.
I'm back.
Okay.
Let's do science.
I got cheeses.
I'm ready to do science.
Father.
hates it when I use up all his chemicals father hates it when I use up all his chemicals he hates it he hurts what's here unlike Halligan Melanie is actually competent maybe mm-hmm let's put a bone here oh I can't think of anything reasonable today just kidding thank you for those super chats.
Thank you so much guys.
Thank you.
Let's put a bow in here.
Okay.
Can't wait for her to get to the salt arc.
I don't know what that means.
It looks just like her.
What's over here?
Oh, what's this?
Whoa!
can I take any of these gone okay what's this whoa forbidden archaeologies my favorite excellent research very mysterious very mysterious forbidden archaeologies my what is so cool thank you so much for the 10 gift and thank you you think we need to yeah this here there's no point in that it won't work like that okay let's try here let's put it in this little thing here it won't work like that are you sure i don't want that okay i have a sliver of bone and i don't know what to do with it
oh my evil twin what could you be doing here wait do you see her well did you get anywhere Ms. Turner not really not yet anyway it'll take a while okay okay I'm glad he doesn't notice her what are all these Minecraft.
This one's spooky.
Nice view for Halloween.
She's still there.
Oh, wait.
There's nothing here to, like, open.
What else?
Oh, what's here?
This side.
The head of a Greek statue.
I keep forgetting these pieces fit together.
But my father and I never managed to figure out where they came from.
I need the right click for like the description.
These sculptures don't belong here.
I bought them from a junk dealer for just 20 pounds.
I ought to take them home with me.
I'll put them in the living room.
A sanity effect like a turtle dying is right.
These sculptures don't belong here.
I bought them.
Okay.
This statue is from North Africa.
I think it represents the God of the Earth.
Whoa.
was there anything else over here uh besides the machine no oh she's gone it's so spooky the sickles from england it could be a celtic artifact but we haven't been able to date it yet that's a stiletto from the late roman era this dagger needs restoring a curved dagger i think father brought it back with him from Turkey.
These stilettos were found during the excavations in Tenochtitlan which is now Mexico City.
Yes, but it happens in real life.
These stilettos were antique muzzleloader pistols.
Pieces of broken vessels.
It must have been practically impossible to aim these things properly.
Probably.
She's back!
My voice scared me!
I know this game I saw someone review this idea.
Yeah!
Was there anything here?
Maybe I just didn't observe well enough.
Anything?
Like, why else would we be able to look over here?
No, nothing?
Okay.
What about in here?
Two bottles of developer.
Developer, like, for pictures?
The wash basin.
Yes.
There's no point in that.
tile as well a wash basin what do i do with this little scrap um let's check here father's distiller okay these are pieces of very old statues it's not easy to put them together microscope i don't see one though oh wait oh my gosh okay
I can't see a thing.
Yeah, I know.
I can't really, like, adjust it that well, either.
Try using the item on the items on the weapon table.
I won't get anywhere that...
No, not a chance.
It won't work like that.
I don't want that.
I'd better think about it again.
Or this one?
There's no point.
It's lucky nobody saw that.
Do I have to...
It didn't give me an op...
Let me try.
The bone.
Ah, there we go.
What is that?
Do-do-do.
I can't see it properly.
No.
Wait, I went too far.
Okay, here we go.
Do-do-do.
I can't see it properly.
Yes, you can.
Don't lie.
some metal residue here it's gold there's some metal residue here gold metal residue gold okay she's back made any progress yes a little but I can't quite make it out have you got a moment I just want to check on something sure no
Okay.
Made any progress?
Yes, a little, but I can't quite make it out.
Have you got a moment?
I just want to check on something.
Sure, no problem.
Sure.
A relief.
It's just come back from the Restorer.
I still control her.
Save the game.
You're so right.
Actually, we'll do Minto too, just in case.
Can I leave?
Let me...
Let's look at this real quick.
Let's look at some of the other things that...
Okay, we'll look at that.
Okay, we'll look at this.
This mask is worn for New Year's celebrations in New Guinea.
I got this mask in Central Africa.
to cure diseases they're witch doctors use them to drive away evil spirits a Mexican God he's obviously hungry and only human sacrifices will satisfy him same a small statue a small Greek statue this is from Easter Island very mysterious a death mask in the Sudan they put masks like these on warriors who died while hunting I'd like to know how my Father got hold of this silver mask from Kenya.
Masks like this one are worn by tribal chieftains for initiation ceremonies.
Hmm.
Okay.
She's not gone.
Okay, hold on.
It's lucky nobody saw that.
Nah, don't think.
Father's distiller.
I think we gotta have him...
Oh, gosh.
How do I get her to leave?
How do I get her doppelganger to leave?
Pieces of broken vessels.
Um...
That's a stiletto from the late...
No!
Uh...
I'm going to like everything that...
Oh gosh, okay, let's try again.
Made any progress?
Yes, a little, but I can't quite make it out.
Have you got a moment?
I just want to check on something.
Sure, no problem.
Restart the save?
Okay, let's try.
Load.
Ow!
Forbidden archaeologies, my favorite.
Excellent research.
Very mysterious.
She is permanent.
Oh, people are saying she doesn't matter.
Oh, really?
Okay.
So there's something about...
Okay, so I need to...
Wait, then what do I have him look at?
Paragon, Paragon.
I'll never get the bone under there.
Do I need to...
Maybe...
Hold on.
Is it like something here?
Something gold?
It won't work like that, I don't think.
Would that really be clever?
That doesn't work.
That won't get me any further.
There's no point in that.
Oh, the tweezers.
Oh.
all right i don't i tried grabbing them before but i could oh we're good
okay i yeah tweezers were a good guess okay she's back um is it so let's see anything else on the desk uh
It's kind of creepy.
What's here?
Okay.
Um...
Uh...
Every copy of the game is personalized.
Bone on the tweezers!
Oh!
Oh yeah, maybe let's try.
Well, it didn't give me...
Oh, whoops, my bad.
Wrong thing.
It didn't give me the option to interact with the tweezers at all, so I'm not sure if it'll let us do that, but we can try.
No.
I think I tried interacting with all of these.
Hmm.
Nothing's happened.
It won't work like that.
I should concentrate.
Is there anything?
Oh, maybe over here.
That could get it out.
No.
Would that really be clever?
Maybe I don't feel like I have to use this, but...
Wanted up to a scam.
Yeah.
It won't work.
That won't get me any...
It won't work like that.
That won't get me any further.
The wash basin.
That's futile as well.
Is it...
The wash basin.
Um...
Hmm.
Ah.
The wash basin.
There was nothing in here to interact with.
Can you, that's what I was trying to do was plug the sink with this, but it just, she just says the wash basin.
She just says the wash basin.
I didn't think, because that looks like the plug, no, that's what I thought.
Big bone on sickle.
Really?
The big bone?
Hmm.
That's interesting.
The notches in the bone were made by a sharp instrument.
The sickle matches the notches to a T.
How are you supposed to know that?
Okay, mister.
Made any progress?
Yes, a little, but I can't quite make it out.
Have you got a moment?
I just want to check on something.
Sure, no problem.
Okay, there's more we gotta do!
Okay.
Ha!
This is the weeks they talked about!
Like, that's why I tried the piece to be like, oh, any of these metals kind of like mad.
There's no point in that.
Okay.
The magazine.
Hey, didn't this edition mention something in connection with sacrificial rights in Britain?
Why didn't you bring that up sooner?
Let's see.
Yes, here it is.
An article about the druids and their sacrificial rights.
Findings indicate that in ancient England, it was probable for the most...
Ah, for their high ceremonies, the Celts usually prefer to use...
Hmm, incredible.
Think about what you're trying to achieve.
What fits in with this bone?
I'm sure the detective will be very interested.
The Druids!
Okay, our house is haunted and also...
Mr. Halligan?
The Druids.
Oh!
I believe I found something interesting about your bone.
ahead.
In my opinion this bone was worked on.
With a sickle?
Yes, and probably with a sickle made of gold.
What makes you think that?
The bone bears notches matching the cutting form of a sickle to a tee.
And I found a trace of gold in one of the notches.
A golden sickle?
Who would use a weapon like that in order to cut a human being to pieces?
That's what I asked myself as well.
I found an interesting article which could help us.
According to the historian Arthur Blake, the Britannic druids carried out very bloody sacrificial rites.
He found out that such rites took place at major celebrations of the Celts.
He assumes that consecrated golden sickles were used for those rites.
And how does he know about these things?
He learned about it from old inscriptions he's translating at the moment.
Interesting, huh?
Interesting.
Celts?
Druids?
Quite some time has passed since then, hasn't it?
Of course, but the descriptions in the article absolutely match the findings on your bone, Mr. Halligan.
I'm sure the author of the article can help you.
Case, happy birthday!
Oh, what do you think?
Could this Blake be right?
What do you think?
I don't know.
Maybe he just wants to make money with horror stories about ancient Britain, but the bone you've shown me would match his theory quite well.
Have you seen anything similar?
This murder could...
Do you think this murder could be a ritual murder?
murder could be a ritual murder yes it would be possible there are several occult sects and Satanists they like checking their history books and adopting archaic rituals have you ever seen anything similar in your career oh mr.
Halligan you don't know the Aztec scar walls oh seen those you'd consider your bone harmless maybe but that was centuries ago the victim of this murder was found this morning and it was found in London found in London Okay.
All right, team.
I think we have to go talk to that guy, right?
What did you say the author's name was?
What did you say this author's name was?
Blake.
Arthur Blake.
Was there any mention in the article of how you could get in touch with the man?
I thought you'd ask that.
His address was printed below the article.
366 Pinewood Road, Northampton.
They're just doxing this man's address in a magazine.
Anybody can buy a magazine.
What?
Okay.
I'm going there now.
Mr. Halligan, I'm interested in this.
particularly because of my job.
I'd like to help you with your case.
Would you take me with you?
It was a different time, truly.
It's confidential police work.
I have to see him on my own.
No, no, no.
I'm sure my knowledge would be to your advantage, Mr. Halligan.
And I think it would be really interesting to work on a case like that.
Hmm.
Oh, when I think about it, perhaps that's not a bad idea at all.
Perhaps there will be more examinations to be done.
Yes.
Okay, Ms. Turner, let's do it like this.
I'll keep you informed on the case.
If I hear anything new or if I need your help, I'll contact you.
What do you think?
All right.
I'll see you later, then.
Yeah.
See you later.
And thank you, Ms. Turner.
Thank you, Ms. Turner.
All right, baby.
Is this guy...
I guess we should check up on...
He's probably still snoring.
Yep.
He's totally fine, everybody.
He can...
He is...
but not a lightweight like all of you.
We're going to Arthur Blake.
Pretty out of the way.
Wow.
Cute little place.
What we got around here.
We got his car.
Mr. Blake's vehicle really is a vintage car.
That's for certain.
Looks like he made this letterbox himself.
Oh, he's a handyman.
How'd you come to my place and have a chat if you liked the article, right?
ping-pong it is mr.
Blake yes my name's Brent Halligan I'm a detective from Scotland yard I have a few questions I need to ask you Scotland yard what's this about is something wrong hello I'm American my name is Blake I come in I'm not sure what's happened is there a problem with one of my publications no no sir I'm investigating a murder case perhaps you could help me it really won't Murder.
How awful.
Murder.
But what's it got to do with me?
Mr. Blake, I'd really prefer if we could go somewhere a little more private.
May I come in?
Yes, certainly.
Come on in.
I love the way Hannigan kind of puts his arms behind his back and like goes on his tippy toes.
Like he's like saying like, please, please may I come in?
Wait, he's gonna do it.
Wow, the music in here is nice.
Scotland forever.
Is Mint playing with a guide?
Yeah, chats my god.
Big bong bong.
Cool.
An old pendulum clock with a Roman face.
What do you got in your drawers?
Mr. Blake seems to be a man of taste.
Still, I wouldn't buy a thing like that.
Oh my god!
I thought that we were so chill for like...
I'd better not sit down.
Might create a bad impression.
The armchair looks really comfortable.
I could do with one of them in my office.
This sounded like Owoni up in here.
A lot of books.
And they're almost all historical works.
Wee!
Okay, where it stops is the next place we're going.
The sea!
Next stop.
Heading to...
Canada!
That's a pretty good map of the world, considering how old it is.
We're going to Canada, baby.
Hello.
You're the author of a book on druids, am I right?
Yes, quite correct.
In fact, I'm just working on a revised version for the next edition.
But what makes you so interested in my book?
I'm currently investigating a series of murders in London.
some interesting discoveries that I'd like to discuss with you what series of murders are we talking about the skeleton murders you may have read about them in the papers oh yes of course a terrible business mr.
Blake I believe there may be some sort of ritual behind these murders what makes you think that dr. Turner from the Anthropological Museum in Oxford examined one of the last victims bones for me she found residual traces of gold on it and round notches round Does that mean anything to you?
Doesn't your book on druids mention ritual killings, for which a golden sickle was used?
True.
Are you saying these murders are based on the same ritual?
That's what I've come to ask you.
But that's impossible.
Oh.
It can't be true.
It's my God.
It would be unthinkable.
Unthinkable?
It would confirm all my translations.
I've been researching the history of the druids for 30 years now.
But I've never yet found proof of my greatest failure.
Fears.
Your greatest fears.
Yes.
The perfection of the final ritual.
The final confirmation of the Druid's power.
I turned the music down.
If I hadn't, it would be like just completely overshadowing.
Tell me more about the Druids.
What's this final ritual, yeah?
What's this final ritual all about?
This is the text I wrote down during my travels through England and France.
You know, when you travel through the country, you can feel that many locals still believe in the old Celtic customs.
A group of farmers in the south of England let me copy the inscriptions on a megalith that stands in a field there.
They claim that there used to be a huge druid temple close to their house.
But there's nothing left of it now.
Frantz.
I managed to translate the text, at least in part.
Okay, Mr. Blake, please come to the point.
Oh my God, you asked him!
It says that the last of the druids saw the fall of their priesthood coming in the year 1000 AD.
surrounding the final destruction of the order.
A demonic superior druid seized power, using his knowledge of druid magic, not for the good of his people, man to honor the gods, but to submit all of mankind to his rule.
No.
In order to secure the survival of the druid's tradition, and to complete his devilish work, he organized a final ritual, transferring the knowledge and power of the last of the druids to five infants.
Oh, the babies!
as the inheritors.
Go on.
The inscription says that the ritual was not entirely completed.
I've not yet been able to discover why.
But from what I've learned, the inheritors are strong and powerful enough to one day complete the ritual by themselves.
Says our movements.
Right, but what do these murders have to do with the myth?
Right.
What have these murders got to do with the myth?
That's just it, Mr. Halligan.
I haven't told you the whole story yet.
Then get on with it!
Yes.
The inscriptions explain that the Druids' inheritors require the life force of other people to complete the ritual.
I see.
And how do they do that?
According to legend, the flesh has to be cut off the bones of living humans and to be eaten.
Only then can their life force be transferred.
You mean the victims of these skeleton murders were practically eaten alive by cannibals.
by druids.
By druids!
I don't believe it.
The worst is yet to come, Mr. Halligan.
What?
What could possibly be worse than that?
If such skeletons have been found in London, bearing marks of a golden sickle, it can only mean one thing.
What?
The inheritors are preparing for the perfection of their final ritual.
Which means?
The myth says, once the ritual has been completed, the world will become a place governed by evil.
We can't have that!
Our magic will be unleashed upon the world, will have but one choice, to obey or to die.
You're great.
And you really believe all that?
I believe it's possible.
You know, Mr. Halligan, I'm not a superstitious man, but I've spent enough time studying Druidism to know that more goes on between heaven and earth than we can possibly imagine.
I quite agree.
You see, and the skeletons that have been found within the past few months fit in perfectly with the Druid's sacrificial rites, is drawing near.
Of that, I'm certain.
What we're looking at right now is just the beginning.
Before we're through, more people will die.
And the inheritors will soon be strong enough.
What can we do about it?
Time is running out, Mr. Halligan.
You must find the inheritors and put them out of action.
How can I do that?
That's an easy thing to say, but how can I?
There may be a way.
During my latest research, I came across something very interesting.
If the story I've heard is true, then there's a certain item that was extremely important for the ritual a thousand years ago.
What is it?
A piece of jewelry mentioned in the old inscriptions.
The amulet of transformation.
You should try to gain possession of that amulet.
The amulet of transformation?
What's its purpose?
I don't know, Mr. Heligan.
Nobody does.
All I do know is that the myth says it's important for the completion of the ritual.
If you find the amulet, you may be able to prevent the ritual.
Okay, I'll bury it in my backyard.
Okay, perfect.
Oh, how did you find out?
How did you find out about the amulet?
My work led to the discovery of a connection between the Druids of Gaul and Britain.
It seems there was a small group of British Druids who fled to France when the ritual failed.
What for?
I don't know.
Maybe they wanted to save the amulet.
I found out that a 13th-century despotic French nobleman somehow gained possession of the amulet.
I found a picture of him in an old archive.
Really?
Let me see.
Yes.
Oh.
I thought we were going to get, like, I don't know, a picture of, like, some archaeologist like, black and white photo.
Oh, I see.
Well, he doesn't look particularly friendly.
Was he a druid?
Well, he must have had some to the music but i really can't tell you how he gained possession of the amulet however he is the only clue that i can possibly give you as to the whereabouts of the amulet i suggest that you make your way to carmore carmore you may find more clues leading to the amulet there thank you mr blake all right mr blake i'll get going immediately i'm so sorry take care of yourself mr Halligan good luck thank you well what can I do for you you can ask me anything you want oh this is the only God had again don't do it he's the only one that's been nice to us being
so personal tell me mr.
Blake why are you in a wheelchair oh a few years back.
Attacked?
Who by?
I don't know.
It was after an autograph session for my first book about the Druids.
A group of men were lying in wait for me and beat me up.
No way!
Had you had a disagreement with someone?
No, not that I know of.
They just beat me up.
Without warning, and without saying a single word.
Then they left me lying there.
Calm as anything.
They just strolled away.
That's terrible.
Who could they have been?
Do you know what they looked like?
They were dressed all in black and wearing dark sunglasses.
That's all I remember.
It all happened so fast.
And you've been in a wheelchair ever since.
Yes.
I can't drive anymore, and I find my work very strenuous.
I'll be grateful if I ever manage to finish my new book.
No!
Oh
my god, the four elements.
Wait, did he mention something like that?
I'd like to know more about the four elements.
The Druids regarded the four elements as the material of which the world is made.
They invoked the elements and used them for their rituals.
And the magazine posted his address.
And Earth.
The fourth element existed solely for the purpose of transferring one of the three basic elements into another.
What do you mean?
Well, solids or liquids become gaseous through fire.
Gas can be turned into liquid form with the help of fire.
Take a mixture of hydrogen and oxygen, for example.
Say solidus.
I dare you.
Fire therefore represents transformation.
The transferal of one element into a new condition.
That sounds pretty complicated.
I suppose it does when you first hear it.
Not organization 13.
But it's actually quite simple.
Yes, well, that's what my colleague Chris Hecker always tries to tell me.
Whenever he starts lecturing me about chemistry.
Quite right, Mr. Halligan.
Yes.
I shouldn't bore you with such details.
No solidus here.
Okay, that's it.
Thank you, Mr. Blake.
That's all for now.
You're welcome, Mr. Halligan.
No, he did the little arm thing so cute.
Okay, goodbye.
I don't know why the music stopped in here.
Okay.
Let's go.
Save reminder.
Thank you.
Minito 2.
All right.
Resume game.
Cool, cool, cool, cool.
Can we just like look in his windows?
Wait.
Not much to see.
I hope he's in.
all right we are headed towards uh whoever he said
uh portsmouth me and my fellow druids crippling and old and ferdelic each other's of our eldritch rituals yeah let's all let's all gang up on that guy and beat him up when i say i'm gonna when i say i'm gonna kick your ass i don't mean like that i think i mean i'm gonna kill you
It's important, but you're about to go to France.
Do not leave Portsmouth when you get there without getting the salt.
Exiting Portsmouth without salt will softlock you.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, Captain.
Bonjour.
Bonjour, bonjour.
When are you leaving for Portsmouth?
In two hours.
Are you coming?
I'll stay here for a bit.
No, I think I'll stay here for a bit.
Very well.
We are in France, oh my god.
Save, I just did, we're fine.
Writes a book about druids, gets beaten up by men black.
Ah, bonjour.
Good day to you, monsieur.
Shush, shush, shush, silence.
Which way to the cat, wait, so I...
I...
Save again, why?
I already got warned you guys.
We're fine.
We're fine But I was gonna clarify I'm not in Portsmouth yet, so I have to get there and to get the salt Stay at the docks until you get the salt.
Okay, that's all I needed to know.
Okay Okay, we're gonna get salt baby You have to do everything here.
Okay.
Tell me my good man, which way is the castle castle?
Oh burnt down mound of rubble on the outskirts of the village I suppose yes that's it what do you want to go there for there's nothing to see there I just want to take a look around water graphics are kind of great actually that's simple just follow the road through the village past the crossroads and straight ahead keep going for about three kilometers then you can't miss it have you heard so the castle burnt down the castle burnt down did it yes that's right I think it happened in some war or other one during the Inquisition but that was hundreds of years ago have you heard of the Lord have you ever heard of the Lord of the castle of Carmore yes of course my parents used to tell me about him in order to scare me when I wouldn't go to bed for the children of Carmore the Lord was a kind of a bogeyman a bogeyman our parents used to tell us horror stories about him what did they say that villages used to vanish that the Lord would catch and kill little children they told me Pierre sleep
now or the Lord will come and get you.
I remember it as if it had been yesterday.
The bow game, oh my goodness.
Have you ever visited the castle as an adult?
Have you ever been to the castle as an adult?
Yes, a couple of times.
The music is so loud.
I need a stone for our new stable.
But I don't mind telling you, I wasn't too happy out there.
Hold on, before, let's do this.
I don't wanna turn the music down.
We can turn the voices up a little bit.
And the music down just a little bit.
Okay.
It's me again.
My God, haven't you been listening?
I'm trying to catch fish, my friend.
Oh yes.
I'm sorry.
Well, how do you like the area?
Have you explored it yet?
Not really, to be honest.
Aha.
Then what are you doing here again?
Trying to scare the fish away, hmm?
No, no.
There were just a few points I wanted to clear up.
Very well.
But keep your voice down, will you?
Certainly.
I can catch a good fish.
Um...
Oh, wait.
I have to ask about the castle again.
No, we're fine.
Alright, we gotta get salt apparently.
Salt in this thing.
I take it these drums contain fuel.
Uh...
How do I get salt?
We're fine, everybody, we're fine!
How do I get salt you have failed the salt arc there's been no mention of salt i have to talk to the cap capitan capitan capitan hello captain how are you how are you all right all right i'm not being very talkative not being very talkative no no do you know the castle of carmore i say i might i might well do you know the castle or don't you
you're not being very talkative no oh well thanks for the conversation you're welcome
it's me again quiet my god haven't you been listening i'm trying to catch fish my friend Oh, yes.
I'm sorry.
Well, how do you like the area?
Have you explored it yet?
Not really, to be honest.
Aha.
Then what are you doing here again?
Trying to scare the fish away, hmm?
No, no.
There were just a few points I wanted to clear up.
Very well.
But keep your voice down, will you?
Certainly.
Which?
Do I ask about the castle?
Tell me, my good man, which way is the castle?
Castle?
Oh, you mean the burnt-down mound of rubble on the outskirts of the village, I suppose.
that's it what do you want to go there for there's nothing to see there i just want to take a look around so which way do i go oh that's simple just follow the road through the village past the crossroads and straight ahead keep going for about three kilometers then you can't miss it kilometers um what do you think about wait yeah got any salt do you know about the castle what do you know about salt not much it's supposed I need salt!
Why is it...
How is...
Wait, I'm sorry, you get soft locked here?
When they don't tell you literally anything about salt?
Why is that?
It's in danger of collapsing.
You could just leave and you would never know.
Anyway, it's pretty creepy out there.
Especially in the cemetery.
Salt locked.
There's not much left of the castle nowadays.
Local farmers use the ruin as a quarry when they need stones for their houses.
There's just a few bits of rubble.
And salt?
Salt?
Have you ever heard of the Lord of the Castle of Carmore?
Yes, of course.
My parents used to tell me about him in order to scare me when I wouldn't go to bed.
Welcome to Old School Point and Glicks.
The Lord was a kind of ogie man, you know.
About ogie man.
Our parents used to tell us horror stories about him.
What did they say?
That villagers used to vanish, that the Lord would catch and kill little children.
They told me, Pierre, sleep now.
And the only way to get rid of him is salt.
It's salt.
I remember it as if it had been yesterday.
Okay, um...
What did people believe would happen if the Lord came to get you?
This has to be about salt.
You'd be killed and fed to the Lord's hounds.
At least, that's what my parents told me.
And he would salt you.
That's not much of a bedtime story to tell a small boy.
Druid.
But it worked.
We kept away from the castle after dark.
Captain's name.
Oh, thank you!
Exhaust captain's dialogue until he mentions salt and druids.
expect 20 plus minutes of dialogue was
the Lord such an evil character oh yes so I've heard he murdered his entire family not to mention half the household he was a madman if you don't do all that you're soft look have you ever been to the castle as an adult yes a couple of times we needed stones for our new stable but I don't mind telling you I wasn't too happy out there so the castle burnt down did it yes that's right I think it happened in some war or other all right this is exhausting all of his dialogue hundreds of years ago okay good luck I have to go good luck with your fishing thank you thank you I didn't get the captain's name did I sir please talk to me hello captain mm-hmm don't you do you
know the castle of carmore i say i might i might well do you know the castle or don't you what loop number is this you're not being very talkative no no i keep forgetting that i can just like exit the conversations whenever i want it's me again quiet my god haven't you been listening i'm trying to catch fish my friend oh yes i'm sorry well how do you like me have you explored it yet not Really,
to be honest.
Uh-huh.
Then what are you doing here again?
Trying to scare the fish away, hmm?
No, no.
There were just a few points I wanted to clear up.
Very well.
But keep your voice down, will you?
Certainly.
I don't want to go through all this dialogue again.
Can I do anything with the fish?
The can?
You are a Metal Gear player.
20 minutes of dialogue is easy peasy.
I take it these drums contain fuel.
Oh,
what was this?
That's so good.
AHHHH!
That's salt.
Take it!
What is the salt for?
Hello, Captain.
What is the salt?
What is the salt for?
How are you?
Oh.
All right.
Oh, wait.
That's...
I think that's all I can do.
Okay.
That's salt.
It's me again.
Quiet.
My God, haven't you been listening?
I'm trying to catch fish, my friend.
Oh, yes.
I'm sorry.
how do you like the area oh my god this whole dialogue really to be honest then what are you doing here again trying to scare the fish away no no there were just a few points I wanted to clear up very well I did all the talking but keep your voice down will you certainly that's salt okay what about salt tell me my good man which way is the castle castle I don't think there's a way to skip dialogue you mean the burnt-down mound of rubble on the outskirts of the there's nothing to see there i just want to take a look around so which way do i go oh that's simple just follow the road through the village past the crossroads and straight ahead keep going for about three kilometers then you can't miss it oh i've done all of these ah
that's so what do you know about the castle ah not much it's supposed have belonged to a rich family around here many centuries ago as a child i used to play in the ruins with my friends but it's not really safe to go walking around in the rubble why is that it's in danger wait i think this one's new anyway it's pretty creepy out there especially in the cemetery there's not much left of the castle nowadays local farmers use the ruin as a quarry when they need stones for their houses there's just a few bits of rubble left that's all yeah so Castle Burdown.
Have you ever heard of the Lord of the Castle of Carmore?
Yes, of course.
My parents used to tell me about him in order to scare me when I wouldn't go to...
Cemetery have solved!
For the children of Carmore, the Lord was a kind of bogeyman, you know.
This guy talked so much.
Our parents used to tell us horror stories about him.
What did they say?
That villages used to vanish.
That the Lord would catch and kill little children.
They told me, Pierre, sleep now.
Or the Lord...
Lord will come and get you.
I remember it as if it had been yesterday.
So the castle burnt down, did it?
Yes, that's right.
Oh, I can skip dialogue!
Oh my gosh!
Have you ever been to the castle as an adult?
Yes, a couple of times.
We needed stones for our new stable.
Did I hear this one?
I don't mind telling you.
I wasn't too happy out there.
um okay what did people believe would happen if the lord came to get you you'd be killed and fed to the lord's hands at least that's what my parents told me how will we know you know that's not much of a bedtime story to tell a small boy true but it worked we kept away from the castle after dark believe me was the lord such an evil character then oh yes so i've heard they say he murdered his entire family not to mention half the household option is just pressing escape i don't remember many details of the old stories handa thank you so much for the time gifted oh i didn't get the name i have to go good luck with your fishing thank you thank you it's me again quiet my oh yes i'm sorry not real aha no no very well certainly okay tell me cut yeah what might i keep oh the what the castle burned down oh my gosh so the castle burnt down did it yes that's right what do you know about the castle uh not much it's supposed to have belonged to a rich family around here many centuries ago as a
child i used to play in the ruins did you click the fishing rod i tried there's nothing why is that anyway there's not much there's just a okay i'm just gonna close out yeah the fishing rod has nothing it will not let me and even here if i click this it just takes me back to this screen ha what am i doing wrong thank you for positive british representation hello captain bonjour bonjour what if i say what time when are we leaving for portsmouth i did save right when are you leaving for portsmouth in two hours are you coming i'll stay here a bit no i think i'll stay here for a bit very well Very well.
Hello, Captain.
Bonjour.
Do you know the castle?
Do you know the castle of Carmore?
I say.
I might.
Do you know?
Well, do you know the castle or don't you?
Hmm.
You're not being very talkative.
No.
Oh, well, thanks for the conversation.
You're welcome.
I'm looking it up.
it up mystery of the Jewish walkthrough I have no idea come on okay quick guide let's see what we have here um okay okay go to Portsmouth go to the other country wait, go to the other country on the ferry in the new map speak to the fishermen and then captain then the fisherman exhaust the dialogue until a cat appears in the zone
get Brent Brent Halligan's model to stand near the barrel in the bottom right did we see a cat
did we see a cat anywhere did we see a cat anywhere When the cat comes out and walks between the lampposts and the crate.
Use the green scarf on the cat.
What?
I talked to them so many times, though.
Make a third save and check the castle.
The key.
Check the castle.
Talk to Pierre.
The issues with the salt arc is that no one knows how the castle can softlock you.
But again, what the hell is this game?
A descheville.
What?
It says it's...
A deschevaux.
Okay.
Probably the fishermen's.
I thought Lowry was the car guy.
Okay, so we go here.
All right, wait.
We...
Cute kitten on bottom right.
Yeah.
The cat only appears after view exhaust.
That's what I thought I have.
Maybe I need to go to the castle and then they say...
Then he says, have you explored the area?
like yes I don't know okay we'll just go and look around must be the castle or rather what's left of it pretty whoa do I want to go in well I saved did she get the salt no that's why we're here the ceiling of the tower has caved in and Okay, maybe I'll try going back now.
Back?
Hello!
How do you know if you're soft-locked?
Is the ship gone?
Oh, we got the BGM back!
Hello, I'm back.
Damn, quiet, I said.
Are you trying to frighten the fish off?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I forgot.
I was miles away.
Oh, here we go.
This is new.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And what do you think of our little village?
Hmm, it's nice, but I've got a few more questions regarding our last talk.
Oh, well, go ahead and ask, but please quietly.
Quietly.
Precisely, Michael.
You don't?
You don't know?
You learn quickly.
Okay.
Um, I would like to speak to you about fishing.
I'd like to speak to you about fishing.
What would you like to know?
I discovered you recently through your karaoke changes.
I just wanted to drop one and say I have one of the best voice and cutest bottle.
thank you thanks for sticking around oh i like your fishing rod i like your fishing rod it's a beauty yes nice isn't it it's an enhanced fiberglass telescope ultra light 47 latest model could you give me one of your fish could you give me one of your fish on a normal day i would but i just haven't been able to catch enough today how many fish have you caught not a single one not a lot yeah precisely I must try to catch some now otherwise I will have nothing to offer this evening you're planning to sell the fish no no I have visitors coming this evening you understand I see I suppose there's nothing doing then sorry why don't you just buy a fishing rod of your own and come and join me who knows nice and quiet you may be lucky um do you mind if I hold your fishing rod do you mind if I hold your fishing rod Sorry,
my friend.
It was very expensive.
I spent 800 francs on it.
And I'm not going to anyone else touch it.
What are you planning to catch?
Ah, you may not believe me, but I've caught all kinds of things here.
You know, I've caught pike five meters long with eyes like plates and razor sharp teeth.
That's why I bought this rod.
The last one was pulled clean out of my hands by one of those beasts.
You expect me to believe that?
of course it's the truth i swear i even had some photos of one of those fish but i'm afraid i lost them they fell into the water right here and now there's not a shred of evidence to support your story that is a pity don't you believe me ask captain de nerve he will confirm it i often show him the fish that i catch we got the name captain de nerve who's that oh you don't know him he captains the ferry that brought you here he's over there on board He's experienced a lot and has been all over the place.
Where's the cat?
He knows a lot of stories.
Incredible stories.
Oh?
Like what, for example?
You'll have to ask him that yourself.
I never really listened properly when he starts spinning his yarns.
He's bound to tell you a story or two.
You just have to know how to deal with him.
Okay, I think we...
Okay, I'm gonna keep...
I'm going to keep, um...
Exhausting this.
Because we still need the cat.
deal with him what do you mean not so loud please because of the fish no because of captain denerve he might hear us and look I'll tell you something denerve's a bit strange he insists on being addressed by his titles it's a how do you call it a peculiarity of his oh why is that he's an old sea dog from a real old seafaring family some ancestor of his served in Napoleon's fleet he himself Capitan!
Capitan!
Got a master's certificate and all that.
Seen the world, so he says...
These days he just captains the ferry.
But he still insists on people using his title.
He says his rank should still command people's respect.
Oh, well, if that's all, I don't mind.
What do I have to call him then?
Monsieur Le Capitan Chaldenerve.
That's his full title.
He'll appreciate that.
Got it.
Thanks for the hint.
Nice, nice.
good luck with your fishing I have to go good luck with your fishing thank you thank you did we see a cat hello I'm back damn he's so loud are you trying to frighten the fish off oh I'm sorry I did the wrong I forgot press the wrong button again I was miles away I've had a look around the area I've been to the ruin and what do you think of our little village when I press the wrong thing it like gets rid of the window for me I've got a few more questions regarding our last talk oh well go ahead and ask but please quietly right precise okay are we soft lock do you think after the captain's 20 minutes okay okay we'll try the cap we'll try to talk to the captain and then but the cat shows up where
I have to talk to the fisherman.
Then the captain, maybe I did then do talk to the fisherman again.
And then the cat shows up, okay.
Excuse me.
What?
You're Monsieur Le Capitain Charles de Neuve.
You're Monsieur Le Capitain Charles de Neuve, aren't you?
Yes, that is correct, my boy.
Charles de Neuve, captain of the Merchant Navy of France.
How do you know my name?
I've been talking to a friend of yours, the fisherman over there at the jetty.
Pierre?
Ah, yes.
Old Pierre.
I expect he has been telling you about his pike.
The one that was five meters long.
Oh, yes.
Yes, he did.
Uh.
Is his story true?
To be honest with you, my boy.
Pierre tends to exaggerate a little.
No.
Just like all fishermen.
The pike was about four and a half meters long.
Is he talking?
No more than that.
Okay.
Okay, you're from here too.
Pierre says you're from Carmore like he is.
Is that true?
Yes, that's right.
I grew up here as a youngster I wanted to be a fisherman and used to work on my father's trawler later I went to naval college to become a captain of the merchant Navy of France.
I miss the I have a small house at the end of the road just behind Francoise Bistro I'm used to tell me more about Pierre.
Tell me more about Pierre.
I meet him almost every day the fishing industry went down the drain.
So he's a fisherman, is he?
He used to have three trawlers and five employees.
But nobody wants French fish anymore these days.
They're too expensive.
Now he spends his days sitting at the jetty, catching a few fish for himself and his friends to eat.
They meet round at his place practically every evening and talk about old times when they used to go out on their trawlers every day.
Whether the cat shows up or not is the soft lock.
Yeah.
I think that's what we're determining.
doesn't he have anything better to do no not much none of the villagers here has much to do since business is so bad nowadays here has a small farm which supplies him with all he needs a few years back he built himself a small stable next to his house where he keeps a few animals his life is rather boring really that's why he's always pleased when I tell him a few stories how long does he sit there fishing until I come back with my last load of passengers since he's had that fishing rod he sometimes sits there even longer oh my god I have time we go over to Francois place when I'm finished for the day he just wants friends thank you monsieur de le captain thank you monsieur le captain you've been a great help you're welcome my boy moment of truth maybe let
me go talk to him one more time excuse me Pierre yeah Yes.
Now what?
I'd like to ask you something about Captain Deneuve.
Have you spoken to him?
Yes, I have.
And you were right.
He's a very strange man.
I think it says that you have to talk to him one more time.
And then we...
Can you really believe everything he says?
Well, I'm not sure quite honestly.
He's a sailor, and they're always full of stories.
Fishermen are full of stories.
Sailors are full of stories.
Enough time to experience a great deal.
things to become a bit muddled up in one's mind he certainly seems to say some strange things i don't think all his stories are true but there's a core of truth in many of them you'll have to make up your own mind which of his stories to believe he didn't sound so far-fetched like is he your friend is he a friend of yours friend well i've seen him almost every day for a number of years he captains the ferry i do my fishing when he's finished for the day we sometimes go over to the should mention that he has a cat yes now I come to think of it I suppose we are friends and you get on well with each other I should think it's pretty difficult being friends with a man like him oh we get on rather well really we don't talk much you know if anything he does the talking spins his yarns the only thing about him that sometimes drives me crazy is his damned cat the captain has a cat yes he lets her out here on the jetty in the morning and takes her back in at night and the damned beast spends all
day slinking around here you don't like cats i hate cats please they steal the fish from my bucket or get tangled up in my fishing line the nerves creature has often knocked my bucket of bait over and i've had to go and get some more i've told him hundreds of times to take the animal on the ferry with him but he just won't mention okay um i'm gonna still exhaust the dialogue since this part why does he only captain a small nowadays yeah he used to command a large merchant ship but then he was dismissed I I think it was because he drank he missed Cape Town Harbor in the fog that could have happened to anyone drink or no drink yes but it so happens that with him it was drink it was actually seeing double in the fog he saw the shadowy outlines of two bays and ordered his helmsman to set course for the one on the right and that was the wrong one exactly there was no right The port had one bay,
not two.
But you'd better keep that to yourself.
He gets pretty embarrassed if anyone mentions it.
You're just gossiping.
I understand.
Jeez, okay.
Okay.
Thank you for your assistance.
Thank you for the secret.
You're welcome.
Thank kitty for good luck.
Okay.
There will be a cat here.
Wait, hold on.
Let me see how it says to do the cat.
When the cat comes out, walk between the lamppost and the crate, use the green scarf.
Okay, here we go.
Let's hope.
Oh!
Oh.
Wait.
I think I needed to get him.
Does he come back out?
Is...
Have to wait?
I'll wait.
This is kind of nice.
It's waiting time.
Alright.
We're waiting.
It's a waiting puzzle.
Cats just do what they want to do.
You know?
Wait for him with the scarf ready.
The minute intervals.
Well guys, we'll...
Welcome to today's...
Zatsudan.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
This is a game?
Yeah.
Um...
What if I went back over there and then... Here, I'll save and find out.
Hold on.
Save.
Binto 4.
Resume.
If I move too quickly, I'll scare the cat away.
Okay, I do have to wait.
Wait, it says wait where.
Wait.
There's no way I can be ready.
The cat just walks away.
To stand near the barrel in the bottom right of the screen.
This is not, this, like here, when the cat comes out, walk between the lamppost and the crate.
Okay, so maybe, maybe down here.
Maybe I'm standing too close.
Okay, this might be good.
And then I have to walk to where the cat, go.
A stealth section?
Okay.
Alright, this seems...
Oh!
There's the cat.
Okay.
Where'd the cat go?
Oh!
First try!
Oh my god, we just catnapped him.
Ooh, nice!
We gained?
Okay.
So then now I go to the cat.
I use the cat.
this dude oh wait hold on I'm gonna save save game me until four save yes resume all right I got a cat oh my gosh captain de nerve's cat a rather stubborn beast and on top of that it has fleas as well no oh the bait there did you see that did you see that it's that damn cat again she's not all my bait in the water that's the third time this week calm down you can always get some new baits what about my fishing tackle what about my telescope ultra light 47 for 800 francs I can't leave it here unguarded it could be stolen I'll have to take everything with me just because of that damned cat don't worry Pierre yeah I'll keep an eye on I'm a police officer of course no problem thank you my friend then I'll go right now time
for salt so then i what do i like combine these is that what it is okay and now we get the salt we look
here yeah oh come on you can do it oh that was a nice chunk more oh yeah that's a good chunk oh yeah oh yeah yeah just licking salt for days we got it we've we got the salt without being soft locked we actually did it we actually did it man
all right guys well i think i'll call it here today um i want to go watch uh common rider in 30 minutes
no way she got through the salt lock yeah common rider third episode is a third is it well it's minutes but I want to go watch it but this was so fun this was so much fun that's two of three soft lock location wait two of three really wait what was the first one.
Hmm.
What was the first one, though?
Thus, Halian steals a fishing rod, so he no longer needs...
He no longer needs for a handful of soul.
Yeah, wait!
We're just taking it.
You good?
You dodge the most egregious one.
That's so funny.
I can't believe this...
I can't wait to watch the videos about this game after everything so that I can...
I can't believe... We did it.
We dodged it very, very smoothly, I'd say.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you had fun.
What season of Common Rider are you watching?
It's the newest one.
Zets.
My gameroshi got past the salt arc also.
Good morning, Ryder.
Isn't it so funny that they say good morning, good morning, Minto?
I mean, good morning, Ryder, and I say good morning, Minto every day.
It's, like, perfect.
Thanks for the stream.
Enjoy comment right here.
It was fun watching.
It's all game.
Good go.
Thanks to Argo.
Thank you so much for the pink.
Faded.
Truly.
Truly, truly.
Okay, okay, okay.
Thank you guys so much.
I will see you when I see you next.
And yeah.
Thank you so much.
See you guys later.
I'm
just thinking about the queen.